hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
this problem appeared on a math exam in
india for 13 year olds
find the sum of all corner angles of a
five-pointed regular star
that is find the sum of a b c d and e
i thank nikhil patro for suggesting this
problem
you have to prove your answer
as a bonus
you can find the sum of all corner
angles of any by pointed star
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so how can we solve this problem
i'm first going to show you a method on
how you can get some intuition of the
answer
it doesn't involve any mathematical
calculation and you can do this for any
kind of problem that asks for this value
where you need the sum of angles
so here's how you can intuitively get
that the answer is 180 degrees
start by placing an arrow going along
one side of this diagram
if you're doing this in practice you can
use a pencil or pen but make sure it's
pointing in one direction so that you
know the orientation of this object
we'll now trace this object along the
angles of this shape
so just to keep track of everything the
arrow started going from angle d to a
going up like this
so now let's see what happens as we
rotate this object through each of these
angles
we'll first rotate this object through
the angle a
now we'll rotate it through angle c so
this arrow has moved a total of a plus c
degrees
we'll now move it along e degrees
then we'll move it along b degrees
and finally we'll move it along d
degrees
so now let's compare the start and the
end
well the arrow is in the same place
except it's flipped upside down
so after the angle rotation of all of
these corner angles the arrow rotates
180 degrees
hence the sum of all these angles is 180
degrees
so while this doesn't prove the answer
it does give us some idea of what the
answer will be
and from there you might think that well
180 degrees is half of a circle or 180
degrees is equal to the sum of the
angles in a triangle
and both of these insights can help us
prove the answer is 180 degrees
so first let's prove that the answer is
180 degrees for a regular star
pentagon because of symmetry we know
that the shape can be inscribed in a
circle
furthermore in a circle an inscribed
angle is equal to half of the angle of
the arc it subtends
so this angle a
will subtend an arc that's twice as
large
so this arc will have a measure of 2a
similarly this arc will have a measure
of 2b
here we have
2c here we have 2d
and finally we have 2e
since a circle measures 360 degrees
the sum of all of these arcs which will
be 2a plus 2b plus two c plus two d plus
two e will equal 360 degrees
now we just divide by two to get the
answer a plus b plus c plus d plus e
will equal 180 degrees
so this is a valid proof for a regular
star pentagon
but it's not necessarily true for any
pentagon because it may not be able to
be inscribed in a circle so how can we
prove the more general result
well here's how we can prove it for any
star pentagon
take a look at this triangle which
involves the angles b and d
the exterior angle to this triangle is
equal to b plus d
that'll be this angle right here
now take a look at this triangle which
has the angles e plus c
by similar logic the exterior angle to
this triangle is equal to c plus e
that'll be this angle right here
so now take a look at this top triangle
it has angles a
b plus d and c plus e
so this will be equal to a plus b plus c
plus d plus e because it has one copy of
each letter
finally
since the sum of angles in a triangle is
equal to 180 degrees we're done
the sum of the angles in this is a plus
b plus c plus d plus e and it's equal to
180 degrees
amazing
now there are many other ways that you
can prove this result and i've provided
links to some of them in the video
description
i encourage you if you have a creative
proof you can make a video please don't
email me i actually don't have time to
review all the great proofs that people
send me even though i do appreciate them
i may not be able to send a reply
did you figure out this problem and what
method did you use
thanks for watching
these math videos which can be watch for
free on youtube inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they already have over 100 million
views let's share the beauty of
mathematics with your help we can math
the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos email me a puzzle or
math topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
and if you so choose you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support